so over the past 12 months i've managed
to rack up a significant number of views
and i thought i'd take this opportunity
today to share with you guys
how much money you can make in such a
short period of time
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about income solely
off youtube ad revenue
in the last 365 days my ad revenue
and my views have gone exponentially up
so unlike the other guys on youtube that
do these videos i'm not going to make
you guys wait too long
what we're going to do is jump straight
in to youtube analytics
and take a look at all the facts and
figures and break it down
week by week month by month year by year
as it stands right now
in july 2020 i'm sitting at about 2
500 subscribers now this might not seem
like a large number
and in actual fact it isn't but the
amount of views and the amount of
impressions i've been able
to generate over the last 365 days that
i've been on youtube
is actually really fantastic and such an
inspiration to myself to see and i'm
hoping
for other people to know that you can
actually grow relatively quickly in a
short period of time
okay so let's move along into analytics
across
on the side what you'll see is in the
last 28 days i've had over 25
000 views 1.4 000
hours of watch time and just under 260
new subscribers
if you're one of those 260 people thank
you so much if you're not
subscribe button's just there so
straight off the bat you can see
that in the last 28 days i've have an
estimated revenue of 190 dollars
now i say estimated because this figure
isn't 100
accurate but it isn't too far off so if
we continue to break this down it
started to increase over the last 28
days and you can see
just as i posted these last couple of
videos
the arcade versus revit and starting a
youtube channel in 2020 that the views
started to increase per day the watch
time started to increase and
i was at a whole new bracket across the
bottom the same thing happened with
subscribers
after i launched that revit video and
the latest
starting youtube channel video it
continuously got more and more and more
every single day yesterday it was
actually 33 new subscribers in one day
which is huge compared to
the one new subscriber per day almost
one month ago so it wasn't that long ago
before there was nothing happening on
the channel
to something happening relatively
quickly now that's important because
when you launch a good video and it
starts to take off it actually makes a
huge difference
most of the videos tend to trickle along
or they just
pump up straight away and die pretty
quickly after that
so having continuous content that does
really really well
is actually quite difficult to achieve
at least in my opinion and my experience
but what you will notice though even
though my subscribers my view count
has gone up it's relatively consistent
across the last
28 days of what it could be and what it
should be
so every single day it's about 10 to
11 12 per day going all the way down to
five
so if we take a look at reach now in the
last 28 days alone
nearly 300 000 people's eyes have been
on one of my thumbnails
that is a huge amount of people that
have seen my face and a little bit scary
in my personal opinion but i guess
that's the whole point of this youtube
venture and
the whole point of just trying to get
out there and reach as many people as
possible
on average it's about seven percent of
the people that see my face
click on that thumbnail so potentially i
might have to do some more work on my
thumbnails to get that up a little bit
because it's gone down nine percent in
comparison to last month
even though i've had a really good
couple videos launched with some
great number of views so if we scroll
down my reach you can see that most of
it comes
generically and organically from youtube
themselves
and then from suggested videos it
doesn't actually come too often from
external pages such as facebook or
instagram or any of my other social
platforms
because i don't have a tendency to share
there too often
but when i do it does tend to bump it up
that little bit
and get those videos going straight away
now i guess more so what you guys are
interested in
is not the engagement of how things are
starting to go up
and not the audience of who you are and
where you come from
but more so the revenue side of things
now this is where it's quite interesting
and quite concerning at the same time
so at top you're going to have three
these boxes the estimated revenue
the rpm and the playback cost
cpm the rpm is basically what youtube is
saying you will get
per thousand views versus what the ad
payers are actually paying youtube
per thousand views which is cpm so
you can tell that youtube is taking a
very large
chunk 60 70 80 sometimes
from your rpm to your cpm so
even though ad players like samsung
apple
and whoever else is advertising on
youtube is
paying this absurd amount of money most
of it is not going to the creators it is
going to youtube themselves
okay so if we switch this over now from
28 days to last
90 days you will see that in the last 90
days versus the 28 days
my estimated revenue is seven hundred
and seven dollars
and with a very similar rpm value of
seven dollars and sixteen cents
so again we're sitting about that sixty
seventy percent loss
compared to what ad payers actually pay
youtube versus to what you get
but 20 of something's better than 100
nothing right
if we break this down on a very basic
point of view there isn't many of my
videos that do absurdly well
it's two videos that make up bulk of my
revenue and that's the wix versus
squarespace vs shopify
which made almost 210 dollars in the
last 90 days
zoom the skype versus webex which made
152.
that's because of the global pandemic
and coronavirus
when i launched that video it was at the
height of the pandemic
everybody was looking to work from home
study from home and communicate from
home
so the zoom skype video was very
relevant
and very topical hence why it did
extremely well at the start but it's now
starting to die off as people are going
back to work
so now if we take a look at the last 365
days
i've been on youtube just over a little
bit over 365 days
but i only became monetized in october
2019 so it hasn't even been a full
year that as you can see here that i've
started monetizing the channel
so in less than 10 months i've managed
to get from making i believe it's about
a dollar a day
the first day i made one dollar and 23
cents
to accumulating that all the way up to
1600
in ad revenue in less than 12 months
so again this isn't a huge thing it
isn't a huge absurd amount of money in
12 months but what it is
is a really nice indication of how you
can see
the first few months when i monetize the
channel it's sat at his own little tier
at the bottom
and then i got a couple videos that did
really well and it bumped it up a little
bit
and then i got a couple more videos that
did really well consecutively
and that seemed to bump it up into the
next tier
so i don't know if this is a youtube
algorithm sort of thing or if this is
just me making something up
but basically when i got those couple
videos that did really really well
my absolute maximums per day after a
while became
my absolute minimums but what's
interesting here now is the fact that
1 600 in estimated ad revenue
is an equivalent to 15.7
000 hours of watch time or 3.2
million impressions now if i go to
lifetime views because i have been on
youtube a little bit over
18 months now that goes up to 3.4
million impressions that means 3.4
million pairs of eyes have looked at my
profile picture or
my little thumbnail and gone yep or no
chance
so out of that whole time period there's
a likelihood of
one in almost 10 but basically
9 of the time people see it they'll end
up
clicking on one of my videos so in less
than 12 months
of monetization and less than 18 months
of being on youtube
i've managed to accumulate almost 400
000 views now if we back date this to
the 365 day mark what you're going to
see again
is that kind of layered tier theory i
spoke about a second ago
when one video does really well or two
videos do really well
it pumps it up quite high and your lows
become your new highs
i think after a little while november
december came around and the bigger
youtubers started getting
all the attention all the views during
christmas period
and the advertisers started spending
money on that my views or
my content one of the two wasn't as high
and as good quality
so that tend to drop off and once it did
drop off it became very very hard
to pick that back up so i think i had a
good
almost six months of very continuous
low end views very continuous low end
traffic towards the site and it was a
little bit
demotivating but it was good to see that
when things started to kick in and
people started to watch again
that that continued to grow very quickly
and as you can see
one video or two good videos can spike
it into a whole new bracket
anyway guys that's all from me today
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button 2020 style
and as always i'll see you next monday